et le décryptage tout de suite de jean
eric branaa historien spécialiste des
états unis bonjour et merci d'être là
avec nous sur rt france on l'a entendu
jean yves le drian dénoncé hier un
défaut de concertation des états unis le
sujet est d'abord celui de la rupture de
confiance entre alliés ce sont les mots
du ministre français des affaires
étrangères finalement donald trump joe
biden c'est le même combat celui de
l'america first
alors là c'est celle que trans
effectivement de comparer les deux
d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui joe biden
va à la tribune des nations unies pour
expliquer justes mots que la page donald
trump chitour john hight rap c'était la
prévisibilité et expliquer à partir
cette histoire là que la politique
étrangère américaine bêta prévisible
c'est aller un petit peu vite alors la
question c'est pourquoi le drian le
ministre français le driot le fait de
cette façon là le calendrier le les buts
français sont ailleurs ils sont de
restaurer et de puissances européennes
ils sont au repos forcé la coopération
russo européenne ils sont éventuellement
d'aller vers une défense européenne et
pour aller surtout ses résultats de
c'est vrai qu'il faut resserrer un petit
peu l'hérault dans l'union européenne
alors on monte le taureau il faut aussi
se faire entendre par ce partenaire
américain et si possible obtenir son
aval pour aller jusque là et là aussi
monter le tout cela sert à cela bien
entendu ça n'est pas du donald trump la
simple fessée que donald trump a déchiré
tous les accords internationaux que ce
soit avec le web elle savait que
l'unesco avec l'accord de paris sur le
climat tout cela avait volé en éclats
avec
l'administration actuelle c'est tout le
contraire qui se passe c'est joe
weisenthal rappelé tout à l'heure à la
tribune des nations unies en expliquant
que ces défis qui s'annoncent au monde
et en particulier les deux qui sont
devant nous immédiatement la cofidis et
le réchauffement climatique ne peuvent
être franchies c'est 2 est un peu notre
édifice ils peuvent être franchis que
tout son sens je sais donc bien sûr le
multilatéralisme qu'il faut s'appuyer
jean yves le drian réagi à la crise des
sous-marins une crise qui est du fait
des états unis notamment qu'est ce
qu'elle dit cette crise de la façon dont
washington perçoit la france aujourd'hui
on se bat et de corriger la crise avec
les sous marins concerne les australiens
il se trouve que les américains se sont
lancés très opportunément dans cette
affaire-là en décidant de remplacer les
français sur une place qui était libre
mais le contrat n'était pas avec les
américains ce qu'elle dit en revanche
cette façon de faire cette plante unis
sme qui est dénoncée aujourd'hui est
certainement à juste titre c'est qu'il y
a beaucoup de ménage à faire dans l'est
les affaires internationales puisque
visiblement au tout le monde agit dans
le secret les uns par hasard vous aurez
être mais s'il n'y avait pas eu de
secret corps effet les chinois qui
auraient appris qu'ils allaient avoir
des sous marins à propulsion nucléaire
qui allait venir dans la région
franchement ça aura été certainement une
autre histoire sur laquelle on débattre
est aujourd'hui donc on peut peut-être
comprendre que sur des affaires
internationales militaire il y un
minimum de secret est-ce que ce secret
doit aller jusqu'à exclure des
partenaires potentiels dans la région
c'est bien l'enjeu du débat est là notre
ministre a raison de monter le taux est
de demander des comptes mais c'est du
salon des affaires au sommet en termes
de diplomatie alors je reformule ma
question que dire cette crise des sous
marins des relations de la france avec
l'allié américain qui visiblement aussi
un concurrent
c'est je vais vous faire la bonne
réponse je crois que notre relation avec
les américains ne change pas
particulièrement l'île il ya c'est vrai
beaucoup de deux porte à faux ou de
choses qui se sont faites de façon
irrégulière dans cette affaire là mais
ça ne remet pas en cause de nos
relations
nos relations restent les mêmes nous
militaires continuent à travailler dans
différents points du globe ensemble de
militaires français sont ils être formés
dans des bases américaines les
américains continuent à être en support
notamment au sahel il y a les forces
américaines qui sont en support de nos
forces françaises tout cela bien sûr n'a
pas été et drôle et ça reste les états
unis restent un allié de la france la
france aux dalits et des états unis et
de deux côtés on sait pouvoir compter
l'un sur l'autre comment est-ce qu'on
réagit à washington face à la colère de
paris on a entendu le ton au ces par
jean yves le drian joe biden de son côté
aurait demandé à ses rapidement à
s'entretenir avec emmanuel macron ça
c'est pour la forme et au delà de ça est
ce que et les états unis sont réellement
sensible à la colère de paris et les
dossiers sont tellement nombreux
actuellement aux etats-unis et sur le
plan intérieur d'abord la pandémie je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure qui est une
vraie crise actuellement intérieur
puisque n'en sortent pas et où même
l'impression d'y retomber alors que joe
biden avait promis les en sortir ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième c'est
beaucoup de catastrophes qui se sont
multipliés aux etats unis pendant l'été
c'est le réchauffement climatique qui
est bien en avant ensuite sur le plan de
la politique intérieure il y a eu des
crises migratoires au texas et une
opposition bien sûr au m'accuse joe
biden il y à des questions économiques
comment sortir de l'ensemble de ces
crises et et sans y laisser de plus pour
c'est bien qu'une fois que j'ai énuméré
ces quelques dossiers il y en a beaucoup
d'autres la question française est loin
loin loin derrière d'ailleurs quasiment
personne de la reprise dont les journaux
en tout cas personne en première page et
quand s'était repris c'était très loin
un autre filet et s'intéresser au fond
assez peu de monde cette alliance entre
washington londres et canberra est ce
que c'est le retour d'un triangle
anglophone est ce que ça peut peser
selon vous sur les relations
internationales est ce que cette crise
des sous-marins va aussi modifier le jeu
des lettres des alliances est-ce que
dernière question est ce que les états
unis finalement aussi près des risques
alors je le crois pas je crois que
c'était en fait de la facilité et là
encore de l'opportunisme pourquoi parce
que des porte-avions à propulsion
nucléaire demande une grande technicité
qui pouvait les piloter bien par exemple
démarrera la britannique et se trouvent
les marins britanniques pouvaient faire
en australie parce que ils obéissent aux
mêmes règles et ils sont tous les deux
membres du commonwealth donc une paille
par le don de la reine les agissent au
nom de la reine la reine elizabeth 2
bien entendu et c'est c'était donc assez
facile à faire maintenant les etats-unis
ont essayé d'élargir cette alliance
voulez vous qu'ils y est dans un sujet
juste avant avec l'inde pour l'instant
ça ne marche pas puisque l'inde veut
garder son autonomie ne pas être aligné
avec le japon même chose avec le vietnam
cet été la vice-présidente kamala harris
était en tournée essayer d'amener les
vietnamiens dans cette dans cet accord
il y aura des demandes qu'ils sentiront
d'autres pays comme avec la corée du sud
par exemple qui va demander également
d'aider la propulsion nucléaire de son
côté après tout pourquoi n'y aurait-il
pas un transfert de technologie plus
vaste c'est plutôt là où les américains
ont pris des risques en oeuvre une
technologie supplémentaire en faisant de
la police et ration de kelleher au delà
des traités qui était qu'ils avaient
même signé pour le reste l'accord
tripartite et l'accord minimaliste qu'il
pouvait obtenir très rapidement dans la
zone merci beaucoup pour votre regard
jean eric branaa je rappelle que vous
êtes historien spécialiste des états
unis